[Music]
hello dear friends Welcome to our
program I'd like to know uh for those of
you who are joining us for the first
time this is our question and answer
program one of our favorite programs
here at Secrets unsealed where you send
us your questions and we do the research
and in so far as possible we try to
provide an answer from God's holy word
amen we thank you very much for being
with us today we have some very
captivating questions that we're going
to try and answer today uh my name is
Steven bore I'm the president of Secrets
unsealed in some TV and I have with me
Pastor David Salazar he is the CEO of
our Spanish uh Channel and our Spanish
work here at Secrets unsealed uh he's
been a great asset and a great help to
our ministry we appreciate him and his
family very much thank you Pastor
Salasar for being with us thank you
Pastor bour for allowing me to spend
time with you studying the scriptures
and to answer the questions that our
friends sent is a blessing and a
privilege to be part of this program
amen uh if you want to send your
questions you'll see the address on the
screen it's an electronic address uh TV
some TV V .org that's where you can send
us your questions tvom
tv.org we would be delighted to get your
questions and try and answer them let me
just warn you that uh we received many
many questions and it might take a while
for us to get to your question but uh we
eventually will so keep tun tuning in uh
of course we want to begin with a word
of prayer never should we open God's
word without asking the Holy Spirit who
inspired the word to be with us to
explain it so I'm going to ask Pastor
Salasar to please have a word of prayer
uh to begin absolutely let us pray
Heavenly Father we are once again so
thankful for allowing us to know your
truth and to know your word and to come
before your throne of grace to seek the
wisdom and the inspiration that comes
from you so we pray that you will uh
grant us the opportunity to receive the
Holy Spirit as we open your word may you
guide us into the truth and lead us to
give answers that are according to your
will according to your purpose we pray
all of these in Jesus name amen
amen okay as I mentioned we have several
really interesting questions uh you know
we learn a lot Pastor Salasar just from
the questions that people send in
absolutely it sends us to the word
absolutely it's a blessing and a
privilege to study the word of God it
send us to the spirit of Prophecy too
that is true because in this program we
uh we use the spirit of Prophecy freely
absolutely uh along with the Bible not
to replace the Bible but to amplify what
we already find in scripture amen okay
so this question comes from Romy David
or David oh too yeah your Nam sake um
this is the question are we violating
the Sabbath day if we exercise in our
own home exercise
machine what about walking for an hour
early in the morning on Sabbath so the
question is about exercise on Sabbath um
what could we answer to this question
well Pastor Bard the first thing that we
have to I think analyze is the what the
Bible tells us in the actual commandment
I think that we just go over that
commandment from Exodus 20 verse 8 we
know there we can get a very clear
understanding of what the Lord sets as
requirements for us for that day so let
us go there first and I'll read there in
starting verse 8 all the way to verse 11
remember the Sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shalt thou labor and do all thy
work but the seventh day is the Sabbath
of the Lord thy God in it Thou shalt not
do any work thou nor thy son nor thy
daughter thy man's servant nor thy maid
servant nor thy cattle nor thy stranger
that is within thy gat
for in six days the Lord made Heaven and
Earth the sea and all that in them is
and rested the seventh day wherefore the
Lord blessed the Sabbath day and
hallowed it so the first concept that I
think is important as we just read from
the Bible is that the day of the Lord
the seven day Sabbath is a holy day set
apart by the Lord for a specific purpose
so all the secular work and that want to
make sure that we kept keep that in this
in mind secular work is what should not
be done on the seven day Sabbath now the
question about exercise what is that fit
in in Isaiah as we know 58 verse 13 we
read if thou turn away from thy foot
from thy the Sabbath from doing thy
pleasure on my holy day and call the
Sabbath a delight the holy of the Lord
honorable and shall honor him not doing
any not doing thy own ways nor finding
thy own pleasure not speaking thy own
words then sht thou Delight thyself in
the Lord I will cause thee to ride upon
the high places of the earth and feed
thee with the heritage of Jacob thy
father for the mother of the Lord has
spoken it so here in this other verse in
Isaiah it's again portraying the concept
that if you do your own thing your own
pleasure in other words that which you
find in a continual type of work setting
something that you do to gain to get
gain to get labor of of profit in a
selfish matter or a in a concept that is
not connected to the Lord then I believe
that that is app applicable in other
words you cannot do that which is a
secular type of activity a secular type
of job something that you find yourself
doing any other day of the week now
however in the exercise aspect is there
anything wrong with walking in nature
absolutely not we can actually read I
have a quote in second T testimonies
page 583 that Spirit of Prophecy will
clearly Define that it's okay to spend
time in nature that we should spend time
in nature now the exercise machine you
know I think that the question should be
asked is this exercise this activity
this aerobic whatever it might be you
know if they're walking in a machine is
it for health purposes to keep a habit
of of being able to have a a good
circulation for
example that experience that work uh if
it's not necessarily
going against the Lord and you're just
for example meditating here in the Bible
and you are just doing a little bit of
cardio work without making it a an
actual activity I don't see it any
different than going outside in nature
especially if you're in the winter for
example if you're in the winter and you
are snowed in you know are we going to
tell somebody oh you cannot do any any
type of walking in a machine absolutely
not I think that's that' be contrary to
keeping a healthy experience but if it's
a full workout and you have to put a I
don't know a video and you know have to
do all those things then I I believe it
takes away from the opportunity to
really exercise your body in a way to
just keep it healthy so I don't know if
this kind of gives an answer but just to
point point prove this point of why it's
important to exercise or to walk not is
what Spirit prophecy says there in uh
second testimonies page 583 it says in
order to to keep the Sabbath holy it is
not necessary that we enclose ourselves
in walls shut away from the beautiful
scenes of Nature and from the free
invigorating air of heaven we should in
no case allow burdens and business
distractions to divert our minds upon
the Sabbath of the Lord which he he has
Sanctified we should not allow our minds
to dwell upon things of worldly
character even but the Mind cannot be
refreshed enlight enlightened and
elevated by being confined nearly all
the Sabbath hours Within Walls listening
to Long sermons and tedious formal
prayers the sabat of the Lord is to put
is put to a wrong use if thus celebrated
the object for which he was instituted
is not attained the Sabbath was made for
man to be a blessing for him by calling
his mind from secular labor to
contemplate the goodness and glory of
God it is necessary that the people of
God assembl to talk of him to
Interchange thoughts and ideas in
regards to the truths contained in his
word and to devote a portion of the time
to appropriate prayer but these Seasons
even upon the Sabbath should not be made
tedious by their length and lack of
interest and then he says during a
portion of the day all should have an
opportunity to be out of doors so this
she's supporting the concept that the
Sabbath it's to be used to spend time in
a walk to spend time in nature to spend
time if you going out in a hike enjoy
nature to see the creation I believe
this is important and in this principle
again if you need to exercise at home
because you have no way to to spend time
in nature you are in like I was telling
you in Winter or something like that or
you are in a city and unfortunately
there's no other way well doing a walk
using a a machine for uh you know for a
simple exercise is fine but if you're
going to be lifting up weights and doing
all those things I think that just kind
of takes away from the concept of what
the Sabbath is
about I think that uh the key is what
your focus is you know it' be much more
difficult to take a walk in
Manhattan than it would uh if you live
out in the country yeah because when you
walk in Manhattan I've been there many
times I've stayed there uh in taking the
subway and everything it's very
difficult to focus on the Lord when
you're walking in Manhattan because
there's so much noise there's so much
other things going on but per se there's
nothing wrong with uh with taking a nice
walk on Sabbath you're getting good
exercise you're taking care of your body
and uh if you're in the midst of nature
you can heal the hear the birds sing You
observe the beauty I believe that on the
first Sabbath God gave the Adam and Eve
the scenic tour of the garden of course
uh you know to and and told them you
know all of this comes from my hand uh
but I think think that uh the the motive
of the person God evaluates our actions
on the basis of what motivates our
actions if our actions are uh to uh you
know take care of our body and focus on
the Lord uh it's one thing if it's
another just uh to keep in shape uh you
know that's something different and so I
think that uh uh we need to apply the
principle and be sincere with ourselves
what is the reason that I'm doing this
and take into account also the
environment in which it's taking place
so the environment would help us I guess
make a decision whether or not we can do
exercise at home if if is necessary uh
you know as you mentioned if you are in
a big city probably walking is not a
it's not going to help you anyway but
maybe in that sense walking but again
like you said pastor I think it's
important you mentioned that aspect of
of taking consideration the the motives
of the heart we need to be be very
careful that we're not like the the Jews
of Christ's day who had a tradition that
you could only walk a certain distance
on the Sabbath yeah and uh that's not in
the Bible I I believe that we need to
learn to apply
principles and we need to be sincere in
other words when we come to the fourth
Commandment there's not a long list that
God gives us what we can do and what we
can't do on the Sabbath the list is very
short buying and selling is one of them
uh you know doing our own work is
another of them but there's no
specificity when it comes to what fits
in those categories yeah so what we need
to do is pray to the Lord and uh
research God's word be
sincere and then if the Lord tells us
this is not right because everyone has a
conscience then we need to follow what
God uh through our conscience through
the voice of the Holy Spirit tells us to
do right pastor and don't uh don't uh
rationalize say well you know I'm taking
care of my body some we we're very very
prone to rationalize what we do you know
it's probably a question that something
that came to my mind if you're an
athlete if you're an athlete for example
you love to run and you know prepare for
that uh you may be tempted to like you
said rationalize I'm taking care of my
body I should you know continue my
training on Sabbath but really it it
should not do that you should stop the
Sabbath because it's a day to actually
connect with the Lord so if you have
that idea of of training and making it
like a everyday routine exercise without
realizing that it is violating that that
separation of the day to make it holy I
think in that scenario as you mention
you have to not do that but if you are
just to keep a
simple um experience of of of of of
walking or something like that and you
cannot for the environment that you are
go out perhaps then walking be okay for
for a sever a couple of minutes you know
nothing nothing that is going to be uh
something that is uh really like a
workout experience okay our next
question comes from Owen
hunga um we get a lot of uh questions
from Africa we get a lot of
correspondents here at Secrets unsealed
uh from Africa this is from
zomia and um actually it's a two-fold
question well it's a onefold question
and he adds the passage that he's asking
the question on in The Book of Leviticus
10 yeah the Bible says that naab and Abu
died because they offered Strange Fire
before the
Lord where were they supposed to get the
fire from and then uh you know I think
basically he says he's asking three
questions but I think that that is the
basic question right uh so let's go to
Leviticus chapter
10 and um read a few verses there uh
because that's what he's referring to
mhm uh are you there bigest 10 okay uh
let's read just a few first few verses
of chapter 10 it says and naab and Abu
the sons of Aaron took either of them
his sensor and put fire therein and put
incense therefore thereon and offered
Strange Fire before the Lord which he
commanded them not and there went out
fire from the Lord and devour them and
they died before the Lord uhhuh now the
person who asked the question also
provides a text that gives the
answer uh Leviticus 16: 11 and 12 so so
where did naam and Abu get the Strange
Fire from it's the fire that God did not
command them to get to to take right
with the incense uh so it must not have
been the fire that God had commanded now
where were they supposed to take the
fire that God commanded from uh
Leviticus 16 and: 11 and 12
uh are the verses that he puts here with
this question it says and Aaron shall
bring the Bullock of the sin offering
which is for himself and shall make an
atonement for himself and for his house
and shall kill the bulock of the sin
offering which is for himself and he
shall take a sensor full of burning
coals of fire from off the altar before
the Lord and his hands full of sweet
incense beaten small and bring it within
the Veil
okay so basically this uh the fire was
to be taken from the altar of sacrifice
right in the court MH that's where the
coals were and then the priest was
supposed to take it into the holy Place
Beyond the Veil the first Veil into the
holy place and mingle it with the
incense and offer it at the golden altar
of incense I think it it's very clear
yeah here and so what did naab and Abu
do they didn't take the coals of fire
from the altar of Sacrifice by the way
the altar of sacrifice was supposed to
burn continually for forever it was
never to go out right and the fire in uh
in the Holy place at the altar of
incense was to burn continually it was
never to burn out correct so Na and Abu
maybe took some uh some fire from where
they were cooking their food or
something like that and uh this shows
that God is very particular mhm when he
said say you know do this he means this
he doesn't mean that because the story
is a tragic story these two sons of
Aaron actually uh the fire that came
forth from the Lord consumed them
because they offered Strange Fire before
the Lord so I hope that that answers the
question I don't know if you have
something more that you want to no I
would just say that there is really no
indication in the Bible where the fire
specifically came out of we don't know
that but it is not from the place the
Lord dis closed it wasn't from the altar
of sacrifice it wasn't coals of fire
from the altar of sacrifice that was
mingled with the incense right uh and by
the way uh the coals of fire uh mingled
with the incense represents the facts
that God the prayers of God's people go
into the holy place they're mingled with
a sweet incense of Christ's merits amen
and that makes our prayers acceptable
before God Amen that's um Revelation 8:
3 and 4 amen okay uh we have another
question here uh High Secrets unsealed
does Jesus continually impute his
righteousness to us to make up for our
deficiencies as we strive through faith
in him to render perfect obedience to
God's
requirements and that without the
imputation of Christ's righteousness to
make up for our deficiencies we should
be lost because the best that we alone
can do is bad if yes what about imparted
righteousness
what does it play what role does it play
in Salvation thanks in advance uh
basically the question to synthesize is
speaking about the difference between
imputed righteousness and imparted
righteousness um uh so so what is the
difference between imputed or credited
righteousness and imparted righteousness
well pastor this is a question that
actually deserves a lot of attention
maybe we won't be able to answer it
fully in this in this small time we have
but unfortunately it's what a lot of
people are now being confused by the
presentation of the concept of gospel in
which the Lord does everything for you
and all you have to do is simply believe
if you will and not that that's not
necessary it's absolutely necessary we
are to believe there's nothing that you
can do on yourself but God does not just
only declare us righteous when we
confess our sins he along with that
declaration he imparts his pardon and
his righteousness to allow us to have
that power to have Victory to be able to
overcome to grow if you will in our
daily walk in experience to reach
achieve or reach that sanctification
that ultimately will lead us to have a
character like Christ it's not something
happens in a moment it's not like you
are just you know completely perfect or
or without any uh struggles but it's
it's a continual growth of Grace uh this
is where for example Psalms
51 it it really describes there the
experience of the true righteousness and
the true uh of both aspects of
forgiveness and of the imputed
righteousness the Lord wants you know
this is a Psalm that is known by a lot
of people because it speaks of David and
his sin and where he says there for
example uh he asks in verse seven Purge
me with his up and I shall be clean wash
me and I shall be whiter than snow make
me to hear joy and gladness that the
bones which thou Hast broken May rejoice
and so he's asking as he's asking for
cleansing he is asking this experience
of making help me give me the power to
enjoy to receive gladness that I
actually rejoice in doing the will of
God so he's not just asking Lord forgive
my sin and forgive my transgression he's
actually also asking to be transformed
that's why it says uh for example in the
um in in verse uh two for example wash
me throughly from my iniquity and
cleanse me from my sin and again that
word cleanse means Purge cleanse take
away that Sin from my heart so this
experience of David of being cleansed of
being pardoned is that imputed or that
uh yeah imput righteousness but the
imparted righteousness is the aspect of
he Desiring to have a different
experience to have a new heart creating
me a new heart he says later put in me a
new spirit this is again the aspect of
making him receive that righteousness
and making part of his life so he has a
a life of victory yeah verse 10 of uh
Psalm 51 MH uh David says create in me a
clean heart oh God and renew a steadfast
Spirit within me so uh David is asking
for two blessings right the first
blessing is forgiveness which is
justification and the Second Blessing is
cleanse my heart so I can live a life of
victory over sin amen uh so when God
imputes his right imputes to us the
righteousness of Christ he also
regenerates us right and he continually
gives us his holy spirit to overcome sin
in our lives absolutely you know Ellen
White wrote a beautiful statement uh and
I'm preaching a series of sermons now
for Secrets unsealed which are going to
be aired in the future uh where she
defines uh imparted and imputed
righteousness she says the righteousness
by which we are Justified is imputed
that means it's credited to us it's
alien to us it's Christ righteousness
that is placed to our account so that
God looks at us as if we had never
sinned she says the righteousness by
which we are Justified is imputed the
righteousness by which we are Sanctified
is
imparted the first is our title to
heaven or our right to enter Heaven in
other words the imputed righteousness is
our right to go into heaven but then she
says the imparted righteousness is our
fitness for for heaven Amen in other
words the cleansing of Sin from the life
of the person so uh do we need imputed
and imparted righteousness in order to
enter Heaven yes you can have the right
to enter Heaven but if you don't have
the fitness you're not going to enter
there absolutely and of course you're
never going to have the fitness unless
you have the the right to enter Heaven
so both are indispensable for for
salvation justification and
sanctification sadly
these days justification is
overemphasized at the expense of
sanctification and we only have like a
few seconds left maybe we can pick up on
this a little bit more in our next
session uh we want to thank you for
joining us today for our question and
answer program I'd like to know um
please remember to join us the next time
it's a pleasure to have you send us your
questions to tvsm tv.org hope to see you
next time God
[Music]
bless